scotland yard that's right confirmed
this morning that they're going to issue
20 20 fixed penalty notices for people
that broke covet rules at the height of
the pandemic i've just come back from a
downing street briefing now as it stands
we do not know who those fines will be
issued to in fact the people in the
building behind me don't know either it
could take up to about 24 hours for the
individuals concerned to be contacted by
the criminal record
organization which dishes out the fines
themselves to the people that have been
fingered for breaking the coveted rules
that boris johnson introduced as it
stands boris johnson himself has not
received one of these fines number 10
has committed to telling us when that
happens but we might not know pretty
much anybody else who gets the names
disclosed publicly by downing street
scotland yard won't tell us who is going
to be getting fined at any point and the
government uh has decided that uh it's
not going to ask staff members and it
won't be told themselves by scotland
yard uh so we could be in a slightly
bizarre situation where there are lots
of people in the building behind me uh
who are found to have broken the law at
the height of covid at the height of the
pandemic and we don't know uh their uh
names we don't know their identities and
we don't know how was it um what's gonna
happened
to them uh as a consequence um but what
also downing street said today is that
boris johnson's going to be reluctant to
comment on this whole affair until after
the police
both the police
investigation is concluded and that
might take weeks if not months for all
of the different lines of investigation
to wrap up but also until after then an
internal government inquiry into what
went on is concluded as well so we could
be looking at weeks and weeks and weeks
until sue gray the official that we were
talking about at the start of the year
concludes her report and then boris
johnson says something to the houses of
parliament because as it stands jane we
are in a surreal situation this morning
scotland yards confirmed that 20
different uh rules were broken at the
height of the pandemic but boris johnson
himself won't accept that the law was
broken number 10 spokesman said that
boris johnson
will just
talk about this in the future when
sugray's report is out but as of now
down history does not themselves accept
that the law was broken even though
scotland yard has confirmed that it has